ich habe schon in der frühen Sendung bei
ihm gesagt dass ich auch für die
Lieferung von den Panzern war und
wir haben keine andere Wahl alles andere
ist in meinen Augen Naivität wissen Sie
wenn ich heute auf die Straße gehen
würde mit einem Formular und da würde
ein Kreuzchen sein wollen sie Frieden
oder wollen Sie weiter kriegen natürlich
wahrscheinlich zu 99,9% würde ich von
jedem Passanten ein Kreuzchen an der
linken Seite ging nicht auf der rechten
Seite aber das ist nicht das Thema hier
ist ein brutale Überfall von der von der
russischen Federation ein auf einem Land
das ist Bruch gegen die
un-karte und die Brutalität dieses
kriege es ist wirklich einmalig ähm die
Zerstörung der Infrastruktur der Versuch
die Leute aussuchen werden
auszuerfrieren die entführ werden die
Vergewaltigungen das habe ich nie
gedacht dass das überhaupt möglich ist
und und wissen Sie was mich natürlich
stützig macht aus der Geschichte ich
meine auch der deutschen Geschichte es
ist nicht nur der Hitler gewesen der
diese Schweinerei eingerichtet hat und
Europa er hat auch ganze Menge Helfer
unterfrage ich mich wenn ich die ganzen
Offiziere da sehe da gab es so eine so
eine Sendung wo er dann vor den
Offizieren sein sein Mister er erzählt
und die hören alle zu und letzten Endes
das sind diejenigen die auch vor Ort
sind und die meines Erachtens auch
verantwortlich sind für diese Verbrechen
und die gehören alle zum nach Haag oder
wo auch immer und das musste
auch seine Helfer und ähm sie sagen also
ganz klar da braucht es als Antwort
einen geschlossenen einen starken Westen
wir sehen gleichzeitig auch immer wieder
ist immer mehr Menschen fürchten kann es
zu einem Atomschlag kommen wie schätzen
Sie diese Gefahr ein also ich schätze
die Gefahr als gering weil
erstens es gab so eine Untersuchung und
ich glaube irgendwo habe ich gelesen von
CIA dass er seine ganzen Atom Dünger ist
in gar nicht so
bereit eingesetzt zu werden also da ist
auch viel
Korrosion und Mist aber abgesehen davon
wie soll das denn funktionieren diese
strategische Waffen wenn man die benutzt
man kann die nicht mehr kontrollieren
egal wo sie die einsetzen an ich sag's
mal in
Odessa oder in Kiel oder wo auch immer
da gibt es Strahlungen und die gehen
danach Weißrussland nach Polen oder war
auch immer und da Leben natürlich auch
ganz mein großen und das jetzt in Dom
basketten vor in der Nähe kommt wie soll
das abgesehen davon historisch gesehen
schauen Sie mal einen Vietnam haben wir
Amerikaner auch Atomwaffen gehabt und
immer wieder Vietnamkrieg verlaufen ist
Wissen auch und Afghanistan haben die
Russen damals als sie angegriffen haben
auch Atomwaffen gab also ich glaube
nicht dass diese Atomwaffen Waffen
benötigt werden er hat die Masse und mit
der Masse wieder den Krieg gewinnen und
letzten Endes geht es ihm um sein
eigenes Überleben verlierte den Krieg
ist er durch
entspannt müssen wir keine Angst haben
vor Atomwaffen naja also bislang ist die
einzige Nation die Atomwaffen eingesetzt
hat glaube ich die Vereinigten Staaten
gewesen den haben gesagt ihren Hiroshima
es gibt schon eine hohe Schwelle dazu
das richtig aber es kann natürlich
extrem Situationen geben also
ich kann mir schon vorstellen einen
übertreten von Truppen in russisches
Territorium das kann zu irrationalen
Konsequenzen mit umgekehrt ich wüsste
gerne was passiert wenn man stelle sich
vor Russland
marschiert in Kiel ein was macht dann
was macht dann Amerika was macht dann
die Nato und deswegen das Thema dürfen
wir nicht müssen wir weiter hochhalten
dass wir
das sie die Führer der Welt wissen die
Menschen in der Welt wollen keinen
Atomkrieg sie sind selber ein Mann der
Justiz ein Mann auch der Fakten
natürlich das aber doch will ich sie
einmal ein bisschen emotional abholen
macht ihnen das Sorgen macht ihnen diese
Entwicklung Angst
nicht sorgen ja jeder Krieg oder und vor
allen Dingen auch ein Krieg so in der
Nähe der macht natürlich schon Sorgen
das ist ganz klar und es gibt Atomwaffen
ich möchte die habe ich teile eigentlich
ein bisschen die optimistische
Sichtweise von Herrn Weinberg es ist
tatsächlich glaube ich so das Atomwaffen
wirklich so dass vor allen Dingen einen
abschreckungswoche sind und dass man
eben wenn man rational denkt oder wenn
man rational kreiert wird man keine
Atomwaffen einsetzen können die Frage
ist einfach wir oder das Problem ist wir
müssen Situationen vermeiden in denen
irrational gehandelt wird in den rote
Linien überschritten werden weil
irgendjemand vielleicht in der Ecke
steht und gar nichts anderes mehr will
also wir müssen so eine Situation
vermeiden in der das dann heißt nach mir
die Sinnflut sozusagen und das wäre dann
eben auch ein das wäre dann wieder die
kluge aus dem Politik von der wir vorhin
gesprochen
die kluge Außenpolitik der noch gibt es
jetzt am Wochenende eine große
Demonstration die ist ins Leben gerufen
worden von Alice Schwarzer von Sarah
Wagenknecht da waren wir da geht's vor
allem darum dass sie fest daran glauben
Verhandlungen könnten zu einem Frieden
führen kommt dieser Gedanke in allen
Überlegungen die wir hier auch in diesem
Tisch treffen auf zu kurz ich glaube
Verhandlungen sind dann erst interessant
wenn beide Seiten sowohl die Russen also
auch die Ukraine und die sie
unterstützenden Mächte zu der Erkenntnis
kommen dass jeder Zentimeter Land
gewinnen mit
unheimlich hohen Kosten verbunden ist
erst wenn sich das ganze Fest fährt dann
ist eine Chance für Verhandlungen da die
Geschichte lehrt uns dass wir da noch
vielleicht Zeit davon weg sind und jetzt
möchte ich vielleicht doch noch auf die
Waffen zurückkommen du kleiner Waffen
sind eher unwahrscheinlich ich glaube
das größere Problem für den Westen ist
die Durchhaltefähigkeit ich höre aus
Amerika Signale ja wir liefern Waffen
aber wir werden die nicht auf ewig und
drei Tage liefern können weil wir
nämlich hier nicht nur die Front gegen
Russland haben sondern auch China im
Blick nehmen müssen Taiwan und wir
dürfen uns hier nicht verkämpfen wir
müssen eben hier das Nötigste tun um
übrigens auch unseren Alliierten in
Asien zu signalisieren dass wir wieder
nicht so rausstolpern aus Afghanistan
oder rosarote Linien ziehen die wir da
nicht folgen also wir hatten vorher
Schwäche haben nicht genug abgeschreckt
haben ein Zeichen der Schwäche gesetzt
wie Europäer sowieso aber auch die
weltführungsmacht war alles andere als
stark so dass Putin eben unsere Schwäche
annehmen musste und jetzt muss Amerika
so viel tun als nötig um eben die
Alliierten Nase und das geht südkorea
Japan Australien andere weiterhin zu
ermutigen Tribute zu zahlen
Handelsgeschäfte Dollar Dominanz und
vieles mehr aber nicht mehr man darf
Russland nicht zerstören sowieso unsere
feministische
Außenministerin vorhatte das glaube ich
wäre keine gute feministische
Außenpolitik dass wir auch nicht gute
Geopolitik wenn Russland nämlich
zerstört werden würde wäre hier in
Vakuum das China nutzen könnte also
Amerika tut nur so viel wie nötig um
Russland zu schwächen vielleicht um am
Ende des Tages vielleicht auch mit
Russland wieder einen Deal zu machen sie
kennen ja das bomo der Realisten in
Amerika hieß der beste
vielleicht nicht mehr mit Putin aber wir
haben sehr gesehen mit dem saudischen
Führer ja auch als ganz schlimmer Kerl
dargestellt wurde und beiden musste
einen Canossa gegangen nach ihr machen
damit die ein Fass mehr aufmachen damit
wir hier die Ölpreise nicht in in den
Himmel schießen sehen also amerikanische
Außenpolitik war immer schon sehr
realpolitisch und wir müssen das
realpolitisch verstehen das hat mit
Feminismus wenig zu tun da sind wir auch
schon fast mittendrin in ihrem Thema sie
hatten gerade die Kosten angesprochen
dieses kriege es ist zumindest natürlich
tragisch die aber es sind auch die
Kosten der Wirtschaft heute eine neue
Studie die Weltwirtschaft hat 1,6
Billionen Dollar verloren durch diesen
Krieg endet dieser Krieg also erst wenn
wir jetzt mal ganz plakativ ausgedrückt
in uns nicht mehr leisten können ich
glaube das ist das kleinere Problem
dieser nach wie vor limitierte Krieg wir
gehen ja jetzt davon aus dass die
Erkenntnis die wir gezogen haben könnten
auch dann auf China erweitert wird wir
haben gesagt gegenseitige Abhängigkeit
das ist nicht kriegsfördernd man hatte
im Endeffekt Unrecht hat auch keine
behauptet wenn wir jetzt diese
gegenseitig Abhängigkeit diese
interpretenzen wegnehmen es kriegt
vielleicht sogar noch wahrscheinlicher
also viele meinen jetzt weil wir mit
Russland blauäugig Waren müssen wir uns
von China rausziehen
ein Flächen der Globalisierung das ist
nicht nur brandgefährlich im Hinblick
auf einen neuen heißen Krieg vielleicht
sogar sondern es könnte ein Alter Krieg
werden bei dem wir diesmal nicht als
Sieger hervorgehen wir dürfen nicht
vergessen dass wir China von heute nicht
mit der Sowjetunion von damals
vergleichen dürfen ich glaube da haben
wir noch nicht wirklich strategisch
weiter gedacht was dieser doch
limitierte Krieg dann auch für massive
weltwirtschaftliche Verwerfungen haben
könnte bei denen vor allem wir hier in
Europa wir hier in Deutschland die wir
sehr abhängig sind vom internationalen
Handel die Leidtragenden sein können
jetzt natürlich schon den ganz ganz
großen Bogen auch mit der strategischen
Ausrichtung die ganze Welt und vor allem
auch Asien mit einzubeziehen ich will
einmal ganz nah an diesem Thema dran
bleiben es hat sich jemand zu Wort
gemeldet der meint eine ganz ganz
schnelle Lösung ist für diesen Krieg
parat zu haben und da schauen wir mal
rein
[Musik]
also Donald Trump glaubt innerhalb von
24 Stunden wäre er in der Lage sofort
einen Deal herbeizuführen zwischen
selensky und Putin er sagt ich sag dem
einen Typen das dem anderen Typen das
und jetzt jetzt findet einen Deal Herr
Weinberg sie sind Republikaner trauen
sie Donald Trump dazu
Donald Trump hat ihn Vergangenheit viele
Sachen gesagt die sage ich mal nicht so
sehr
realistisch bezogen waren und
diplomatisch zu sein
aber
was er damit also meine ich jedenfalls
ausdrücken wollte dass er das war seine
seine direkte Politik hat dass er zu den
Entscheidungsträger immer direkt
gegangen ist und hat bestimmte Dinge aus
dem politisch auch erreicht zum Beispiel
eine Beziehung zwischen manchen
arabischen Ländern und Israel das hat er
direkt erreicht
er hat auch
sage ich mal einen gewissen Respekt beim
Pudding gehabt
und auch der chinesische Führer als er
in Amerika war da hat Trump den roten
Teppich da in malago in Florida
ausgeführt weil eben noch immer glaubt
wenn man zudem exekutiv
exactiv hingeht da kann man besser
direkte Sachen erreichen als wenn man
diplomatisch ich habe das jetzt schon
mal erwähnt durch irgendwelche Kanäle
versucht zu erreichen und
nicht alles was der Donut hat in der
Vergangenheit auch gesagt hat muss man
wirklich nehmen das äh also man muss es
ein bisschen auf eine andere Ebene
bringen das klingt ja fast erfahren
heute ein bisschen sowieso ein
Immobiliendeal in Manhattan natürlich in
anderen Deal aber sie haben ein bisschen
geschmunzelt steckt ja für sie ein
bisschen Wahrheit drin auch in dem was
gerade gesagt hat dass man
mit den direkt Beteiligten spricht also
ich sehe die Äußerung von Trump eher als
ein Zeichen dafür dass warum sagt Trump
das in Amerika doch weil offenbar auch
in den Vereinigten Staaten bei den
Menschen dort eine große Sehnsucht nach
Frieden besteht und nach
friedensverhandlung steht denn sonst
würde das nicht machen der ist ein viel
zu kluger Taktiker als er das sich nicht
vorher überlegt hat also wenn er wüsste
dass 90 % sozusagen lieber jetzt den
Durchmarsch nach Moskau haben wollten
dann hätte er das nicht gesagt und das
zeigt mir eben auch dass er
möglicherweise
eine eine
Tendenz in der amerikanischen
Bevölkerung wiedergibt die sagt wir
müssen jetzt auch wieder von Anfang
miteinander zu reden in jeden Tag den
wir nicht miteinander reden sterben
tausende von jungen Männern und Frauen
natürlich und Menschen in der Ukraine
vor allem die Republikaner sind nicht
mehr bereit das zu machen die neuesten
Umfragen belegen die Demokraten ja aber
bei den Republikanern ihrer Partei
bricht sehr vieles Weg sowohl in der
Bevölkerung als auch dann in Washington
schauen Sie Kevin McCarthy Speaker auf
der House er brauchte 15 Anläufe und nur
ja dank einiger Hilfe im Hintergrund ist
er dann doch über die Ziellinie gegangen
und der hat auch vorher versprechen
müssen dass es keine blanco-checks mehr
für die Ukraine geben würde und der Deal
war nach dem 15 Wahlgang das hat vorher
nur noch vom Bürgerkrieg gegeben dass
einer solange gebraucht hat ich will
jetzt keinen Bürgerkrieg vorauszusagen
obwohl das auch einige ihre Kollegen
machen auch Republikaner auf der ganzen
Ebene sondern der Punkt ist der der Deal
war das einer von diesen verrückten die
auch Trump neu stehen reicht um Kevin
mccasi dann haben wir wieder aus der
Hand zu nehmen das heißt wenn es dann
jetzt um die Schulden Obergrenze geht
und die Auseinandersetzung wird heftig
die Welt Finanzmärkte sind schon nervös
dann werden die Amerikaner sicher nicht
am eigenen ja sparen sondern sicherlich
dann auch den Europäern sagen Freunde
der Sonne ihr habt bisher zu wenig
Waffen geliefert wir könnten einen Deal
machen ihr bezahlt die Waffen die wir
den ukrainen liefern und wir regeln das
auch so dass ihr den Wiederaufbau zahlt
und ich glaube das ist absehbar da muss
man nicht viel von amerikanischer
Politik verstehen um zu sehen dass vor
allem die Republikaner die machte
Geldbörse nutzen werden um den
Präsidenten Bein hier die Hände zu
binden und die Europäer einspringen
müssen
weil das war typisch ich sag mal linke
deutsche nativ was hier da gelegt haben
sprechen
danke schön
also die Wahl von der Kathi war eine für
mich und für uns als Republikaner und
auch für die amerikanische
Öffentlichkeit Lehrstuhl in der
Demokratie
das war immer in den in den Reihen von
Demokratie zugrunde geht oder nun also
wenn sie jetzt mich hier
unterbrechen
mit dem diskutieren also sorry wir
versuchen das jetzt noch mal eine
Antwort jetzt auch
viele Demokratie das heißt man hat auch
die Meinung der Minorität in eine Partei
Berücksichtigung wollen und durchsetzen
wollen das ist Nummer 1 Nummer 2 diese
Untersuchungen weiß nicht wo Sie gelesen
haben auch die Republikaner zumindestens
50% der Amerikaner der Republikaner
genauso wie den äh Demokraten sind für
die Unterstützung von der Ukraine und
zweitens der einzige Unterschied
zwischen den Demokraten und den
Republikaner in dieser Hinsicht ist dass
die Republikaner sagen kein Blanco
Scheck wir wollen wissen wo das Geld
geht
wir glauben in die Demokratie neue
Demokratie in Ukraine aber wir wissen
auch um die Problematik der Korruption
und deswegen bitteschön das Geld was wir
von dem amerikanischen Steuer zahlen
zahlen hier die Schecks ausstellen wir
möchten eine Kontrolle behalten also das
so wie sie das jetzt dargestellt haben
da habe ich absolut andere Meinung
vielleicht noch jetzt drauf das ist
jetzt kein Linker missverstanden ist
werden David mackentos hier das war ein
Abgeordneter den sie vielleicht noch
kennen im Abgeordnetenhaus indem ich
übrigens auch mal gearbeitet habe
der arbeitet jetzt für den Körper groß
und nicht die Partei bestimmt wie andere
als Senator als Abgeordneter da gibt's
dann noch andere die dahinter stehen
also wir müssen uns von der
Missverständnis verabschieden als
Parteien in Amerika wirklich eine Rolle
spielen es sind club for crows es sind
Leute wie Leonard Leo der jetzt wieder
1,65 Milliarden Geschenk gekriegt hat
wenn sie es nicht wahrhaben wollen lesen
Sie es nach in der New York Times die
Geld regnen lassen können die dann
bestimmen wer wo welche Positionen
herzlichen Glückwunsch und ich kenne
haha
persönlich seit 20 Jahren also ich
brauche
mich
Vorreden zu dürfen jetzt darf ich bitte
den Gedanken Weiterführen der vielleicht
neu für sie sein könnte also es sind
sehr viele mit sehr viel Geld im
Hintergrund die einfach nicht wollen
dass dieser Trump wieder kommt der wird
merkantos wird jetzt alles tun um Trump
zu verhindern er sich aber nicht sichern
da gibt's ja viele Geldgeber die jetzt
hier von Trump Abstand nehmen aber
keiner kann sich sicher sein ob er nicht
doch wiederkommt ronde Sand ist soll
aufgebaut werden das entscheidet nicht
die dabei sondern das sind Leute im
Hintergrund mit sehr viel Geld sie
vertreten zwar die Partei im Ausland
aber sie vertreten eine
schattenorganisation dies nicht in
diesem Verständnis gibt wir haben hier
starke Parteien sie in Amerika haben
nicht Parteien wenn es eine Partei
gegeben hätte dann hätte diese Partei
Donald Trump verhindern können in der
Stunde in der Demokratie entschuldigung
das ist sehr schön dass sie jetzt in USA
oder unterstellen das USA hat keine
dokumentativ
ich habe gesagt die Demokratie Probleme
sonst wäre eine
relativ in ihn etwas nicht passt wäre
Präsident ist oder im Senat dann kommt
die Linke und sagt ja ihr habt doch gar
keine aktiv ich habe
um die Demokratie
kennen sie denn wissen
gespendet hat in dem Wahlkampf wissen
Sie wer von euch Demokratie wenn Geld
eingesetzt wird in Amerika das ist doch
eine Lehrstunde der Demokratie ja
zum zum grundsätzlichen Thema
zurückkommen wir haben ja über Trump
gesprochen der gesagt hat wir müssen
reden ich bin kein Trump Anhänger aber
da hat er recht wir müssen reden wir
müssen sozusagen beides machen wir
können wir müssen kämpfen und wir müssen
reden beides also es geht nicht es geht
nicht dass wir sagen hey wir kämpfen nur
wir versuchen gar nicht erst zu reden
das wäre ein Problem und das Umgekehrte
geht auch nicht wenn du sagst na ja wir
hören jetzt auf zu kämpfen wir wir
ergeben uns und wir reden nur das geht
auch nicht wir müssen das ist ja das was
die die auch die US-amerikanische
Politik und die europäische Politik in
den letzten während des Kalten Krieges
auch geprägt hat dass wir sagen wir
haben beides wir haben militärische
gemacht und Verhandlungsbereitschaft und
beides und das ist letztlich das so habe
ich Traum verstanden dass er auch sagt
naja wir dürfen das Reden nicht
vergessen da hat er recht
vergessen wir das Reden derzeit zu sehr
naja jeder der
auf diese
Ebene der Verhandlung nur zusteuert wie
jetzt vor kurzem der französische
Staatspräsident wird ja europäisch und
weltweit gepäscht das ist ja Augenblick
offenbar
nicht
gewollt das zeigt dass wie offenbar oder
zumindest die die mediale Mehrheit der
Meinung ist
man könnte Siegen gegen das ist glaube
ich jetzt im Augenblick sonst würde man
ja verhandeln ja aber ich denke ja ich
stimme mit vollkommen zu niemand hier in
dieser Runde wird im Zweifel ziehen dass
es richtig ist
die Ukraine instand zu setzen dem
Überfall Widerstand zu leisten aber wir
haben jetzt schon fast ein Jahr lang
vermissen lassen mal die Fühler
auszustrecken
um zu wissen wo sind denn wirklich diese
sensiblen Grenzen sie sind da auch habe
ich das Gefühl sehr
vor schildert sie sagen man muss ja
richtig auf
passen sagt man müsse verhandeln ist man
in der bestimmten Ecke drin haben Sie
das Gefühl dass man derzeit in so einem
Klima lebt dass wir in so einem Klima
leben dass man sagt ja moment mal ich
möchte erstmal feststellen ich bin
natürlich aber ich möchte gerne auch mal
das sagen
ja ich kenne das ja aus meinem Metier
der der Klimadebatte nicht wenn man
sozusagen da etwas unabhängiges äußert
dann ist man gleich eine klimaneutralier
ja ja
da komme ich gleich zu aber hier muss
man eben aufpassen dass man nicht gleich
abgestempelt für den anderen
ein Putin Freund zu sein das ist
deswegen jede noch so neutrale
Überlegung wie sie sie da gestellt haben
wird ja gleich in eine eine Kiste
gepackt und das ist einen ein generelles
nach der Nachteil dass wir nicht mehr in
der Lage sind offene Debatten zu führen
und bei der Klima Debatte ist es genauso
was hat man zu verlieren was befürchten
sie denn wenn man offen ist
werden ausgegrenzt sie werden nicht mehr
zu Talkshows eingeladen hier ist das
Gott sei Dank nicht der Fall aber ich
war früher Stammgast bei den
Öffentlich-Rechtlichen aber seitdem ich
sozusagen mich vom Mainstream der der
Regierungspolitik
sie kritisiere
komme ich da nicht mehr vor die werden
wie gesagt meine Frau geostet ja sie
werden sozusagen als nicht mehr
existierende Person dargestellt nicht
das heißt sie würden jetzt nicht am
Wochenende fast Brandenburger Tor gehen
die große Demo das Friedens Manifest von
Sahra Wagenknecht haben allein in der
vergangenen Woche schon eine halbe
Million Menschen unterschrieben sie
würden aber sagen da gehe ich lieber
nicht hin
also ich habe mir das natürlich auch
überlegt und habe mir das angeguckt aber
ich habe genug eigene Baustellen als
dass ich mir sozusagen noch eine weitere
Bashing Baustelle an andere ich finde
es ist das gute Recht zu demonstrieren
aber man hat es offenbar verlernt das zu
akzeptieren das ist auch in Deutschland
Leute gibt die eine andere Meinung haben
ich will mich jetzt gar nicht äußern
dazu euch pro oder
contra da bin aber selbst die Diskussion
darüber ist schon vermietet und ich mer
auch dass hier am Tisch plötzlich alle
ein bisschen stiller geworden sind und
nicken besteht an diesem Punkt den wir
hier gerade gehört haben den Herr
Fahrenholz schildert so ein gewisser
Konsens geht es Ihnen auch so wir kommen
gleich zu ganz deutlichen Worten von
ihnen herabel da wollen wir noch mal
ganz tief in das Thema einsteigen zum
transatlantischen Bündnis aber haben Sie
das Gefühl man muss schon ich überdenke
noch mal setze gerade in Themen wo man
vielleicht leichter in eine Ecke
gedrückt wird empfinden
ich habe vor 30 über 30 Jahren gedient
und damals ja dieses wir hatten die
Stellung bis richtiges Militär kommt
gemeint waren die Amerikaner die uns
geschützt haben die die Schutz macht
sind ich musste mir anhören dass er da
zeichnen Mörder von Leuten übrigens die
jetzt fordern dass wir ganz schwere
Waffen liefern die dafür gesorgt haben
dass die Bundeswehr eigentlich keinen
Militär ist im eigentlichen Sinn also
entscheidend ist nicht das was wir
machen oder nicht machen da müssen wir
die Kirche im Dorf lassen und da bin ich
ganz Beine im Endeffekt wird Amerika
sein ob es Amerika den strategischen
Willen hat durchzuhalten oder nicht hier
in Europa oder uns diese Aufgabe
überlässt da können wir jetzt zweierlei
Meinung sein aber ich bin da eher
vorsichtiger sie haben weniger zu
verlieren sie können wieder nach Amerika
gehen wenn sie sich irgendwie wir müssen
weiterleben mit dem Fakt dass vielleicht
in Amerika Trump wieder kommt und der
mit Putin einen Deal macht der Trump der
seinen eigenen Geheimdiensten weniger
traut wir sind Helsinki gesagt der als
einem FSB Mann Putin der kann wieder
kommen sie können mir keine Garantie
geben dass er nicht wieder kommt wenn
man das nüchtern ab wiegt und auch wenn
er nicht wiederkommt und der beiden wird
sich Amerika weiterhin noch Asien
abtreffen hier Asien und das haben sie
jetzt sehr weil man kann gleich auch
darauf antworten ich glaube hier gibt's
auch gleich noch mal eine gute
Diskussion aber sie sind wirklich
abgezockt oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung das
kann ich Wahnsinn jetzt melden unsere
Reporter kümmern sich um Ihren Fall
vielen Dank
wild kämpft für Sie